hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights shut up
Freddie I'm doing my intro welcome back
to five nights of [ __ ] boys I am about
to do my next shot because it is the
christening of this brand new episode
where we're playing this oddly hilarious
game and I imagine going to be more
hilarious after I get done with this
bottle here not that I'm gonna clear the
entire bottle but you have an idea what
I'm talking about so salud and cheers to
everybody around the world good health
one of those good fancy toasts that
everybody knows about but I don't show
by oh all right okay mmm mmm I filled
that one up too a bit to the brim there
okay so now what I need to do is I
having a goddamn clue so we're just
gonna explore around and wander shut the
[ __ ] up
Freddie try to do something here okay so
what we're gonna do is we're gonna
explore around and I'm actually gonna
head down to the Security office what I
didn't just decide until I was gonna do
that and go right now so that in mind
we're gonna do that cool
cool I mean this is not about some oh I
guess I could have fought the other
camera uh-oh oh the power meter shows
the danger of the area oh okay so this
is like a level one area this would be a
level three area Oh makes so much more
sense okay so what I'm gonna do is I can
go I know where I need to go next well
first of all I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
fight that son of a [ __ ] up there I
need more tokens god damn it why didn't
that farm tokens and the goddamn
intermediary a one you guys weren't
watching because I was too ready to get
to my next shot that's why
alright screw you don't have it ready
I'm just doing this to get tokens
because for some reason I only get the
same number of tokens per each one that
I fight like every enemy only ever gives
five unless I wasn't paying attention
they actually do more than that I have
no idea why am I not cutting away for
this farming routine in the hospital
like suffering away cuz my intestines
were gonna explode and now I'm not gonna
talk about that disgusting thing with
the NG tube just ask anyone else who has
that an NG tube and they will tell you
all about the horrors of an NG tube
but either way just that shots kick in
and then waiting for the next episode
roll along so I can have an own shot and
then by episode 9 of this series I'm
going to be thoroughly wasted and
regretting my life tomorrow but either
way I've got nothing else to do tomorrow
so I'm going to be fine oh it's one of
you yeah suck my dong or inhale my dong
enragement yeah I didn't know what that
was from I don't think it's is that from
here or was everyone just quoting it
from here inhale my dong enragement
child ok so what's gonna happen is I'm
gonna fight this [ __ ] camera but
you're not gonna see the fight you're
just gonna see it to the end because I
don't have spent too much time cutting
away for the goddamn music
because that's something that Wade
warned me about there's a lot of gobby
right abuses like what's going on right
now I may not sound copyrighted but
trust me in the original it is
[ __ ] all over electronics cuz I am
freddy freddy fazbears my name leis I
don't know where the night of debauchery
is coming in because apparently
everything's just going hunky-dory yeah
I know you did Freddie what wait no wait
was that mean what the [ __ ] is that
oh just cuz I was what do I do about
that what do I gotta go find the puppet
well where's the puppet where's the
music box oh I gotta go wind-up a music
box or something what am I gonna do oh
oh what a dick
he's just doesn't understand you Freddie
he doesn't understand you like I do so
what do I do about the puppet I don't
goddamnit
I have time for this okay the timer is
still running even though we're
obviously No you won't go to the kitchen
okay maybe it's over here
maybe I gotta go over here okay goddamn
why he shut the goddamn doors well he's
gonna be safe from the puppet but he's
gonna run out of power I'm gonna do any
of this why is happening where's the
goddamn puppet box
oh okay so we could okay so we can
appear anywhere that there's one of
those platforms I'm guessing or you may
just be here because you think so what I
need to do now is I need it I need it I
need to farm up more because I need a
lot more idea this is what I need
killing these goddamn cameras takes way
too goddamn long pay attention now
because I don't know if the token things
actually
for what I needed to do why Scott damn
puppet mechanic here I know it's a good
puppet it's good it's good okay so they
get twice as many tokens as the other
one I'm guessing that the other dude is
going to give more than what a head Oh
foxy has lead health cool that's a thing
okay yes I would like to buy things yes
I would I'm gonna farm in this area
because I could be a puppet so I'll be
right back when I'm really strong like
really strong I don't know if I'm
actually having fun at this game or if
I'm just enjoying the moment of what I'm
doing which is just playing video games
for a living a nice drink at this point
check in with me six episodes from now
just jump in in the future if you're
watching this look at the time when it
wasn't released to the regulate god [ __ ]
it Neil whatever whoa when I get a king
that sounds awesome magic hook dropped
by cool I don't know when that happened
but that seems unfair that Foxy's attack
would be that high okay oh there's an
optimize but okay I doubt that's that's
much simply that's much simpler does
that even happen I didn't even know I
could get that how did I even find that
I just wasn't paying attention I guess
Jesus I'm an idiot time to beat some
cameras absolutely yes we're gonna [ __ ]
this guy up something foxy
foxie holy hell in a handbasket what the
[ __ ] you didn't do goddamn [ __ ] Freddie
[ __ ] it was all foxy the [ __ ] I don't
know I think it took the whole this
episode isn't for kids thing for granted
because oddly enough oh never mind
forget I said anything
carry on with your day hope your [ __ ]
series for whatever purpose that it's
serving other than being weird weird as
all hell okay
so where is you oh in the bathroom of
course I was just in the bathroom I need
to make sure that I don't take care of
the puppet I gotta make sure that
Freddy's not gonna die in one hit he's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] or something I need more
back you probably diggin well I mean it
isn't number three okay so I'm just
gonna get another I'm gonna get more I
need more pizzas what I need yes inhale
dogs what is with you and inhaling dogs
so I need a lot more of these heal up
with these and then I'm gonna be better
and then I'm gonna fight that camera
whatever I wasted one on Bonnie there
but hey Bonnie needs to eat absolutely
yes let's do this because foxy holy [ __ ]
well that doesn't seem good wise Bonnie
poisons why did you do that - Bonnie I
gotta go find a cure for that now that
cost me money spewed marijuana so ojika
became stoned is that such a bad thing
damn it stop everyone's gonna be so
stoned
45 damage way to go chica way to go
6,000 not bad not bad at all
oh yeah indeed Oh Bonnie but he's
probably not doing too good
thanks back we got to get back we got a
cure P Annie I don't know if that
poisons ever gonna clear on the Sun's up
Balloon Boy you're gonna get it part
yeah you just wanna get solved for oh I
don't know if I've like found any other
things for anyone else but I mean maybe
Foxy's not gonna be here the whole time
that's why I'm able to get that or maybe
I just got really really lucky twice
because I got two of those
sons-of-bitches
what am I even doing I'm doing something
I'm wasting time that's what I'm doing
anymore these I need this I need the
birthday I'll take a couple I guess I
don't know I'm probably gonna need a lot
more of those in the future but whatever
okay Bonnie yeah stop being poisoned
like an [ __ ] wouldn't my fault shut
up Barney you know you're responsible
for all your actions your finger for
your actions pop one more into the
puppet you know what I mean and then
move on my way okay I got more cameras
to be I think the next camera is gonna
be over here
no I already beat this one I beat this
one into the ground okay so I guess the
next one's gonna be in Fox's room
there's gonna the foxy pirate Cove one
comeback a big event I'm gonna beat you
oh you're gonna be a little four or
something have you met my friend foxy
he's about to [ __ ] you up
Oh Oh these guys have a lot of help Wow
not that much foxy I don't need to do
anything else but left foxy take care of
all the business Oh what I should do is
I should go unlock the next balloon boy
in that way I'm gonna have more
equipment that I can get I'm not just
relying on foxy for everything even
though Foxy's Fanta four stars mmm might
be a bad choice let me just let me get
the UH let me get the other let me get
the other thing activated and then I'll
be able to do that okay you're just
scammers right okay you're just
canvassing scammers are fine I just beat
up a group of three games so you're not
gonna be any problem with me I mean the
other guys aren't even doing it she
could just like no damage why evil why I
guess she's hitting him with a cupcake
I'm fighting hard to find justification
for what I'm talking about here but I'm
trying my best
bear with music I know what I'm doing
okay hello Balloon Boy yes inhaling dong
I know you're obsessed with inhaling
dongs okay so I need to buy Freddy that
plus 40 is a lot good strawberry cupcake
yeah screw that I'm not even gonna deal
with that let's get the guitars large
piece of shields good for Freddy like
those the body skeletons those are
pretty good upgrades but I don't know if
they're the best upgrades optimized come
on Sam we're good okay so we're doing
much better than we were before
hopefully by a little bit and a lot okay
so now I should be able to kick the ass
of this thing no let me heal up to full
before I do that Jesus I need a large
pizza on demand not just for chica I
mean I guess I could turn medium sodas
into health
wait a minute yeah why am i buying
health if I can just get chica to heal
everyone else with her skill because her
skill does a thousand health so all I
should be buying or sodas right because
medium soda runs like 150 takes 50 to
heal yeah
then god dammit always even pay
attention I'm such a [ __ ] idiot this
goddamn fireballs getting to me okay
yeah engage the camera mother fum / oh
[ __ ] I wasn't oh god I forgot about all
[Music]
that
cheater doing 15 damage I know you think
you tossed out the last guy with your
piddly little damage but that's actually
not doing anything oh oh
crit 446 thank you very much chica
you're the best it's not going well try
to heal someone put polygraph okay we're
fine I'm fine yeah
Bonnie's only dead it's okay he's
somehow still walking but he's very dead
okay so I got it I got a buy an item to
just be able to wait how do I pick him
back up
oh no I was on farts that's right oh
there with that but yeah the medium soda
I could just buy medium so doesn't get
she gonna heal everybody that sounds
much better so I need to revive what
else do I need buddy
the medium sodas because he just said
that they need to play medium toodles
okay so now I do this I do a little bit
of this save cuz I did good Bonnie's
dead not that anybody cares but I
suppose I should do something about it
BAM okay I'm poisoned so I got a
birthday present for me and then I've
got chicas special healing skills that
she's so advertised whenever she talks
to us oh she can revive god dammit chica
okay I found out white chicas here just
chica gonna actually do [ __ ] all right
let's get this chica
she's got full dad with that in there
with this over here put that right there
you dare and you're okay you can just be
done with you okay God now I'm starting
to give this game I'm starting to get in
the RPG mindset but I'm not
doing anything good about it but I will
just bear with me I'm gonna get to the
bottom of this I'm beating cameras
slowly and steadily she can slowly and
steadily is gonna win the race and I
need oh god I need to get back to the
puppet
yeah just dear I dare you puppets or
hats to come after me whatever boop doop
thank [ __ ] why are you in the bathroom
anyway you sacks of crap just die I'm
getting really strong so now I just need
to get enough equipment or tokens that I
can get the equipment from the next
bloom boy and I don't even know if
there's a future how long is this game
where's my night of debauchery I thought
it was gonna be banging women what not
me personally but I mean as freddie was
gonna because he wanted a night of
debauchery here's a fuck-boy and as
everyone knows [ __ ] boy you see snake to
[ __ ] and I don't know but either way I'm
gonna beat this guy into the ground all
right okay good
oh man okay everyone's level 16 or 15 is
what I need to do I just realize this I
don't know why I didn't think about this
before but chicas last skill
I need that because it's probably the
thing that cures the ailments so when I
do that chicas gonna be able to do
everything
hey maybe I don't know if this is true
but I mean whatever that's not what I
wanted it to be but hey at least that's
interesting I guess well I know it
inhale my dog means I just don't know
what a what an enragement child is okay
gimme gimme
bloop bloop okay Liberty blabbity bloop
you go you need blue wait hand blue blue
this is good there we go okay getting
into my rhythm everyone bear with me
okay we're good okay so I need good I
beat I can be level four cameras like it
ain't no thing so what do I do after
that I mean the only thing I need to do
now is go down
oh the hallway cameras those are
probably level fives so what I need to
do is any to farm up women such that I
can get to the the
hallway cameras and from the balloon boy
in the hallway on the left let's try to
come in I guess there's anything Thank
You chica you actually did something
dude I think this is because our attack
isn't high enough to penetrate the
defenses of anyone else right now anyway
so I'll be right back be right back
I think I got the best equipment I'm
gonna get so I should be able to beat
the camera now unless the cameras at a
higher level than this but it's in a
level 2 hallway so I'm assuming there's
this camera can oh no it's got alright
so what do I do now I guess I go to the
other hallway and beat that one I'm
almost done with all the cameras how
long is this game is there gonna be
stuff more after this am I trying to get
out of here such that I can have a night
of debauchery for some reason these guys
are really easy
who would have fun okay so we're
victorious we got that we're good we're
good we're going for right I know we're
good we get a good we have a poppy
yes I know you did it Freddie good for
you pat yourself on the back a little
bit more because you're poisoned cuz
you're an [ __ ] or something yeah it's
really annoying that I have to do this
every time wait oh yes okay so chica can
do the healey magic - Freddie I don't
want to know how that's done but hey it
is done I mean ignoring the fact that
it's disappears it was okay so now I
just need to kill the two cameras on the
sides of those doors and then I don't
know what else it would be but those are
probably level 5 dudes but I mean to be
honest there's really not much else I
could buy in terms of an upgrade unless
I just happened to find another thing so
hang on let me just clear out here and
make sure that I'm good and then I'm
gonna try I don't know if it's gonna
work but I'm gonna try okay yeah I guess
it's just like the endoskeletons and
it's like minor boost to defense all my
attacks are good I think I just need to
get enough items such that I can heal
myself for the various things that would
happen while I'm in the fight presents I
need at least No I need just sodas just
sodas because chica can revive someone
Solon's chicas alive but then I have oh
that's right out
like one more I would need at least one
at least one I have sodas I have sodas
okay so I prepared I'm mentally prepared
for this fight and it's gonna be good
oh it's gonna be good so it's a level 5
it's got to still be good on your [ __ ]
yeah what's - I'll quarter camera I wish
I could do that whatever that sounds
cool
I want foxy to be able to do that but
I'm not gonna have him give them a so
dumb enough Oh chica yeah better
horrible error this may have been a
terrible terrible error
oh crap skills please rush down him
chica please try Oh God you need a [ __ ]
doc it's balls oh crap
so that was it god damn it
[ __ ] I'm not doing good I'm not doing
good
oh [ __ ] okay she needs to revive why
can't you have 200 health please god
damn it
[Music]
I was not prepared I was not prepared
oh that's good that's good no dammit
that's good that's good that's real good
oh good horribly horrific ly in terrible
ways that everyone is gonna laugh at me
forever and ever but what I'm gonna do
is in between the next episode I'm going
to farm a bit and then take my next shot
and then I'm on farm of it and I'm gonna
farm and farm until I'm strong enough to
be able to beat them because I wanna
beat him I got the heart of a champion
yeah so thank you everybody so much for
watching I'm having like a lot of fun
here I don't know particularly why I'm
having a ton of fun so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always
[Music]
[Music]